こんにちわ！はじめしゃちょーです！
はいというわけで今ですね
AVANTIS HOUSEにいるんですけどもぅ(・∀・)
過去の動画で
過去の動画覚えてるか？
はい？
iPhoneをてんぷらにする動画を過去撮ったのですけども・・・
くぁｗせｄｒｆｔｇｙふじこｌｐｗｗｗｗ
おらああああああああ！
あははｗ
えば？え？
ｗｗｗ
モックのアイフォンに変えてそれをてんぷらに揚げて
本人は自分のアイフォンが天ぷらにされたって驚いちゃった
っていうドッキリだったんですけども
今回はそれのMacBookバージョンをやろうと思います
どうやったらそらちぃのMacBookを天ぷらにできるかって色々考えて
とりあえずMacBookのモックていうものはないです！無かった
だから本物のMacBookでやるしかないと思って…
かといって自分でMacBookを壊すのもちょっともったいないし
確かに…
大炎上するじゃないですか…
だからとりあえずMacBookを壊さずにどうやったら
そらちぃのMacBookを天ぷらにできるかと思ったときに…
はい！
こちらを手に入れました！こちらなんと…
ジャンク品のMacBookでございます
わぉ！（棒
もぉ　わざわざネットで探しまくって
完全にぶっ壊れてもうどうしようもないMacBookを見つけました
ご覧ください　画面はもう割れてて
ほんとっ　ジャンクだからね！
トラックパッド飛び出すぎでしょ
これはもう煮くなり焼くなり好きにしていいMacBookなので
今回はこの完全にジャンクと化したMacBookを
はい！
天ぷらにします
なるほど（棒
これがジャンクのMacBook　こっちがそらちぃのMacBookでございます
はい！
完全にｗｗｗいやもう奇跡的にシール貼ってないっていう
確かに　しかもほぼまんまだし
ほぼまんまだよ
というわけでえっともうすぐそらちぃが今から帰ってくるんですけども
上手いこと彼（そらちぃ）にばれないようなタイミングでMacBookをすり替えて
僕がバーンつったらバーンって持ってって
天ぷらにして彼の反応を見てみようと思います
なるほど
とりあえずは…
天ぷらの準備だ！！！
さぁ　ミッション開始だ！
聞き取り不能…
そらちぃ　ちょっと
返しなさい(-.-)
えっ？
取り押さえろーー
うわっ！
なに？なに？
ちょっ　待って待って何何？
ｗｗｗ
押さえろ！　取り押さえろ！
待って　待って　おい！(# ﾟДﾟ)
やめろ　マジで！(# ﾟДﾟ)
おーい
ばかーー
うわｈｂヴぁｂｂんｊｗ
ｗｗ
ほんとに俺のじゃん
おい！ひゃｃｓｂ
聞き取り不可能
いくよーーーー
ｗｗｗｗｗ
あぁぁぁ
はぁ？(*´Д｀)
いやいやいやいや
それほんとに俺のじゃんこれ
と見せかけて…
偽物でした…
氏ねぇぇぇぇぇぇぇぇ！
も↑や↓も↑や↓も↑や↓も↑や↓も↑や↓も↑や↓も↑や↓も↑や↓
もぉ↑　や↑し↑の↑漢↓字↓
[糵]み↓ん↓な↓で↑　お↑ぼ↑え↑ま↓しょー↓
[艹𠂤辛米]こ↓れ↓ら↓を↑　ちゃ↓ん↓と↓　組↓み↑合↓わ↑せ↓
も↑や↓も↑や↓も↑や↓も↑やっ↓
もっ！糵っ！♬
【新着ニュース】
台風 週明け西日本接近の恐れ
米 北朝鮮への渡航を禁止に
キラ容疑で夜神月に逮捕状
広瀬すず劇中歌でCDデビュー